es un movimiento social que se parece
más a una carrera de fondo
undécima jornada de movilización este
jueves en toda Francia para exigir el
retiro de la Reforma de las pensiones
una huelga que empieza a costar mucho
dinero pero no hay duda estos
trabajadores no serán tenemos un fondo
de huelgas sólido alimentado por la
solidaridad que nos permitirá aguantar y
mantenernos en pie dos semanas después
de la adopción del proyecto vía decreto
el futuro de la Reforma ahora depende de
la decisión que tome el consejo
constitucional el 14 de abril Mientras
tanto hay que esperar un descenso de la
movilización en el sector ferroviario se
prevé que sólo tres trenes de cuatro
entran en circulación y el transporte
público se vea menos afectado en
comparación con los días anteriores en
las escuelas los principales sindicatos
prevén un 20% de huelguistas una cifra
que también desciende en París
recolección de basuras se reanuda
progresivamente desde hace unos días
pero el sindicato cgt ha lanzado una
nueva convocatoria de huelga los
sindicatos esperan aprovechar la
intransigencia del gobierno para
reactivar la movilización la primera
ministra nos ha dejado con una negativa
rotunda y ha preferido devolvernos a las
calles Ya se está preparando una
duodécima jornada de movilización para
la semana que viene el ejecutivo Confía
en que el movimiento se agote Al
comenzar las vacaciones de primavera
este viernes por la noche